this is a production of Cornell
University
so the hard part here
is really hard to imagine from the fly
or beetles point of view what it's like
to be here this is the scale of the
building across the street for you and
me right for a beetle or a fly this is a
high-rise tower and so when they're in
that chamber with all the flowers around
them and it's hot and it might be a
little narcoleptic because it sits
there's a lot of carbon dioxide in there
and so they might get a little sluggish
and it's in there bathed in odors odors
that release behaviors that are reflexes
for them they're not even you know
optional it's hard to imagine what it's
like for them to be in there what we do
know is in all the trap flowers there's
a rhythm when the heat turns off or the
carbon dioxide turns off where the scent
changes then they mobilize they leave
and we don't know when they leave in
this flower because we've been watching
it in greenhouses instead of in Sumatra
so on DJ but whether that's mine day or
twos to here Wednesday of the spathe
here will begin to pull away ok and
you'll and what you'll see you can just
see that a little bit here is I don't
want to do that too much but it's it's
it's flushing yeah it's beginning to
flush with with with pigment ok when
it's fully open and you may have seen
this on photos it's it's a rich burgundy
almost into violet it's quite beautiful
to me actually and they're very very
textured but that'll come away that over
maybe six hours on the final day it'll
sort of come away like a skirt ok and
then you'll be able like the konjac
plant to look down into it ok and you'll
be and you'll be able to see there's a
there's a high color contrast in there
because the burgundy goes down and then
and then it shifts completely to yellow
so this is really strong visual contrast
involved there's also a lot of texture
all of these pleats and folds are not
going to be lost ok this becomes a
funnel so it's pretty remarkable it's
something that might I remind my
students a lot is that even though we're
focused very much on the chem
cool aspects of this because that's a
frontier in our field this is a
multimodal experience for the animals as
well as for us color shape texture
temperature okay ambient things like
like carbon dioxide and oxygen as well
as very very strong and informative
odors so that'll come that'll come away
Paul do you remember how it was it hot
to your touch Ellen yeah yeah it's it's
maybe 38 centigrade it gets its it's at
least 10 degrees above 10 degrees
centigrade above ambient which is
astonishing yeah yeah yeah this this
won't this won't move or change what is
interesting and is very poorly
understood is at the height of the
thermogenic event of the heating this
will start to exude fluid that's right
and it's not clear to us yet this hasn't
been well studied whether that fluid is
coming as a secretion from the cells on
the surface of the cuticle here or
whether it's condensation because of the
huge thermal gradient between the
surface of this thing and the atmosphere
around it either is possible but what
what some people have done is Japanese
study that is just published actually
collecting the fluid and looking at the
chemistry of it it's passively absorbing
a lot of chemistry so this is a the
tower stays as it is the space becomes a
skirt and it opens and then you can see
down into it and then I think the males
are on the bottom on the top what's the
order
okay that's that's typically the way it
is in arrow is that the female florets
are on the bottom the insects are often
on the bottom with them and then they
have to walk out over the meal and
that's a nice way of not getting your
own pollen you know on your own flowers
because it's not yeah and so then you
get to think about the plant
compartmentalizing its reproductive
biology here is using carrion mimicry to
into to affect pollination but then
fruit dispersal is kind of honest
advertising to birds and mammals who are
really interested in the color orange
and red it's very very bright we have
photos on the website of how visually
enticing these fruits are if you've seen
a jack in the pulpit fruits here in our
in our forests its scale data as Paul
says like a medieval mace
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu